und dieser tag ist ein ganz
entscheidender tag für unsere gaspreise
in deutschland die knall ja längst durch
die decke und jetzt macht der kanzler
das zur chefsache endlich chefsache
gaspreis olaf scholz wird gleich bei
siemens zu besuch sein in mülheim bild
natürlich live dabei und dort bei
siemens da geht es ganz konkret um die
russischen gaslieferungen die hat putin
ja auch deshalb so gekürzt weil er sagt
mir fehlt eine ganz wichtige deutsche
turbine die ihr mir wegen der sanktionen
nicht rechtzeitig repariert habt jetzt
gleich wird der kanzler persönlich genau
diese so wichtige gasturbine besichtigen
und klarmachen nein putin die ist fertig
die isra pariert es gibt keine ausrede
mehr die gaslieferungen zu kürzen
deutschlands wichtigste turbine sie
wiegt 20 tonnen ist rund 14 meter lang
eine maschine wie ein monster und längst
ein politikum denn eigentlich soll sie
helfen russisches gas durch die 1200
kilometer lange ostseepipeline nord
stream eins zu pumpen doch seit wochen
liegt die turbine lahm wird gewartet
repariert weit weg in kanada und putin
sagt ohne diese turbine gibt es noch
weniger gas für euch deutsche
eine ausrede denn die turbine ist längst
wieder fit liegt fertig gewartet in
deutschland bereit den nord stream
dienst wieder aufzunehmen
doch russland hat die monster maschine
immer noch nicht zurückgenommen jetzt
macht die bundesregierung druck grund
natürlich unsere deutsche gaskrise der
kanzler selbst besucht nun siemens in
mülheim und die wichtigste deutsche
turbine die botschaft des kanzlers hier
ist die maschine putin es gibt keine
ausrede mehr die gaslieferungen weiter
zu kürzen wie groß der druck jetzt schon
ist in dieser gaskrise das zeigt ein
neuer preisschock einer der größten
gasanbieter deutschlands der zieht die
preise an aber richtig
mega gaspreiserhöhung in deutschland
rheinenergie macht den anfang und drückt
uns die neuen preise rein und zwar satte
133 prozent die leihe tranken die kölner
bevölkerung zum ersten oktober steigt
der gaspreis für mehr als zwei millionen
kunden um mehr als das doppelte an der
preis pro kilowattstunde gas klettert
von bislang 7 87 cent auf 18,3 cent das
ist ein anstieg um 10 43 cent pro
kilowattstunde für einen deutschen
durchschnittshaushalt mit einem
jahresverbrauch von 10.000
kilowattstunden bedeutet dass rund 1000
euro mehr eine steigerung um über 100
prozent
das gas ist teuer fast 450 prozent mehr
als letztes jahr geschuldet dem krieg
und der fehlenden russischen lieferungen
vor zwei wochen geht kanzler olaf scholz
noch bei einer vierköpfigen familie von
einer umlage von 200 bis 300 euro mehr
im jahr aus energieunternehmen dürfen
diese umlage auf die bevölkerung
abwälzen
aber da gibt es einen haken bei der
rheinenergie erhöhung ist noch nicht mal
diese gartenanlage mit eingerechnet die
kommt nämlich noch obendrauf der hammer
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
geht sogar von einer fünf prozent
erhöhung aus und die familien trifft es
hart im extremfall sind das sogar fast
1000 euro mehr ein ende ist erst mal
nicht in sicht
ja und an diesem so wichtigen tag für
den gaspreis in deutschland an diesem
tag an mit der kanzler dieses thema zur
chefsache macht meldet sich er hier
plötzlich groß zu wort gerd schröder der
altkanzler der alte putin freund warum
soll ich mich entschuldigen so fragt er
im stern sich selbst und alle anderen
und damit schwingt er sich auf zum
großen problemlöser tenor dort in diesem
interview mit ihm hätte man jetzt keine
gaskrise wäre doch ganz einfach sagte
auch die zweite nord-stream-pipeline
einfach in betrieb nehmen dann wäre
alles gut krieg egal und schröder sagt
auch moskau würde den krieg so gerne per
verhandlungen beilegen also mehr dazu
gleich alt kanzler schröder der sich
ganz groß zu wort meldet hier heute wie
gewohnt als treuer putin freut und egal
ob gas oder strom wir alle sollen und
wollen ja auch alle kräftig sparen
überall wo es nur geht und an anderer
stelle da wird noch kräftig energie
verschleudert bei den ganz großen bei
der bahn zb der riesige bahntower hier
in berlin am potsdamer platz licht an
auch wenn nachts dort niemand mehr
arbeitet darüber hat bild berichtet und
das hat gewirkt sagt die bahn wir machen
das licht nach feierabend jetzt
revolution aus dass zumindest das
behauptet der konzern ab jetzt ja wegen
der weltweiten energiepreise licht aus
nach feierabend stimmt das wir haben das
gezeigt heute nacht liegt wirklich aus
bei der bahn dass die bilder also vom
potsdamer platz ja da hat man den
schalter
tatsächlich erwischt bei der bahn paar
lampen brennen noch möglicherweise hat
der ein oder andere ja tatsächlich auch
noch gearbeitet
oder doch noch mal vergessen den
schalter zu drücken aber da hat sich
schon etwas geändert also statt festtags
beleuchtung tatsächlich nur noch in ein
paar büros ein bisschen licht vor allen
dingen oben in den vorstandsetagen
vielleicht tatsächlich doch noch
gearbeitet worden also ohne verspätung
diesmal nicht im wesentlichen aus geht
doch deutsche warten schon guten morgen
das ist bild live an diesem mittwoch an
dem wir den mutmaßlichen mörder von
eileen kennen den jungen mann also der
die 14 jährige aus dem kleinen
gottenheim in baden württemberg getötet
haben soll das ist der mann der selbst
schon mit 14 jahren nur versucht hat ein
mädchen zu missbrauchen zu vergewaltigen
was ist das für ein typ was hat der für
ein leben gelebt da bild kennt die akte
von jan hajek kopie aus dem hessischen
wald sei es dem mutmaßlichen mörder von
ali
29 jahre vorbestraft und mutmaßlicher
mörder der 14-jährigen eileen das junge
mädchen von diesem mann mutmaßlich
online geködert im auto verschleppt und
ermordet jan p kein unbekannter bei der
justiz was den anwohnern hier
aufgefallen ist sind gelbe briefe von
der staatsanwaltschaft die sich wohl
immer mal wieder an seinem briefkasten
gestapelt haben er soll vor langer zeit
schon den führerschein verloren haben
trotzdem aber immer mal wieder mit neuen
autos angefahren kommen sein doch die
weiteren verbrechen des 29-jährigen
mannes so viel verstörender als
straftäter
im jahr 2007 mit gerade einmal 14 jahren
begeht jan p seine erste straftat
ein gericht verurteilt den jugendlichen
damals zu sexuellem missbrauch
gefährlicher körperverletzung und
versuchter vergewaltigung seine strafe
zehn jahre in der
forensisch-psychiatrischen klinik
2017 endet der dortige aufenthalt mit 24
jahren wird jan p entlassen doch auf
antrag der staatsanwaltschaft kommt dann
ein überwachungsprogramm für
rückfallgefährdete
sexualstraftäter
am 25 januar dieses jahres endet das
programm jan b bekommt weiterhin
führungsaufsicht
die ermittler wissen jetzt es dauert
nicht lange bis der 29-jährige nach
seinem nächsten opfer sucht weniger als
sechs monate später verschwindet die
fahndung beginnt die ermittler werten
alliance online aktivitäten aus und
entdecken ein chat seit einigen wochen
mit einem unbekannten über das
onlinespiel fortnight also das größte
videospiel weltweit ziel dabei ist es
alle seine gegner zu töten als einziger
zu überleben während des games können
die spiele miteinander schreiben so auch
aline und ihr mutmaßlicher mörder jan p
die polizei ortet das handy von alliance
chatpartner in der nacht von alliance
verschwinden lockt es sich am teufelssee
in hessen ein die ermittler gehen
inzwischen davon aus diese nacht
überlebt das 14 jährige mädchen nicht am
28 juli stürmte das sek
anwohner haben uns erzählt dass wohl
alle bewohner auf die knie gezwungen
wurden durchsucht wurden auf der suche
nach dem mutmaßlichen täter der sich
allerdings zu dem zeitpunkt nicht im
haus befand er wurde dann schlussendlich
dagegen von frank geholt festgenommen wo
er wohl auf einem arbeitseinsatz war er
soll als wachmann gejobbt haben
parallel der grausame von palins leiche
im teufelssee seit einiger zeit treibt
sie bereits im seewasser jan p sitzt
seitdem in u haft und schweigt zu den
vorwürfen zu diesem grausamen mord
wie konnte das passieren wie kann es
sein dass ein sexualstraftäter der zehn
jahre in einer psycho anstalt sei es
sich einfach so ein opfer sucht 14 jahre
alt schützen wir unsere kinder genug
nein das findet karsten stein ein mann
der offenen worte der ehrlichen wollte
ein mann der sich den kinderschutz zur
lebensaufgabe gemacht hat und den ich
jetzt ganz herzlich hier bei uns im
studio begrüßen möchte ich in guten tag
hallo simbach es geht ihnen das herz als
sie von dem fall ein lean für dem tod
dieses 14 jahre alten mädchens gehört
wie viele kinder noch wie viele kinder
noch ist sie endlich verstehen dass es
so nicht weitergehen da in unserem land
schützen wir täter mehr als kinder und
die gesellschaft wie viele kinder müssen
noch sterben missbraucht werden
vergewaltigt werden geht ja nicht nur um
kinder sollen frauen bis wir endlich
verstehen dass jetzt so nicht
weitergehen darf für mich hat
kinderschutz oberste priorität ist auch
unverhandelbar dass hier viel versagt
wurde dass dieser junge mit sicherheit
schon als kind auch schlimme erfahrung
gemacht hat ist das eine er kommt frei
er wird überwacht und visa die
überwachung zum schluss aus dass einmal
im monat jemand vorbeikam wie beim
bewährungshelfer wie konnte so etwas
passieren
niemand wird als täter geboren werden so
gemacht das weiß ich aus eigener
erfahrung aber hier hat wieder komplett
das system versagt und wieder ist ein
kind tot und was wird daraus geschehen
was wird sich verändern nichts wenn wir
nicht endlich aufstehen und sagen es
reicht wo ist die politik wo es die
justiz ja die zahlen zeigen ist
konstante zahlen von 2005 bis 2020 15
jahre dutzend fahrer 100 waren 1000
fahrer kindesmissbrauch tausende von
opfern und die 160 180 tausend opfer von
missbrauch und die täter wird bekommen
die den meisten 80 prozent von den zwei
jahre freiheitsstrafe
uns davon 90 prozent auf bewährung
bewegung was ist mit neustrelitz im
endeffekt die gleiche geschichte wie der
junge schon vorweg hat in neustrelitz
bekommt der täter sofort keine
haftstrafe und war 15 was muss noch
passieren
meine tochter ist elf jahre alt wie
wollt ihr mein kind schützen muss ich es
selbst schützen und kann nicht sein und
deswegen fordere ich hier von der
politik sich nicht nur darum zu kümmern
in europa die europa polizei zu spielen
sondern vor allen dingen anzufangen
unsere bürger unsere kinder auch zu
schützen die helfen überall und das
machen wir ja aber datiert ist wie immer
versagen und das wird dann wieder ab
deklariert als bedauerliche einzelfälle
sind endlich jetzt sind so viele kinder
die noch leben könnten weil die
gesellschaft versagt und weg sieht und
weil die politik versagt und wechseln
und die justiz ja mehr täter toleriert
als kinder schützt ist die wahrheit was
hätten sie sich für diesen mann über den
wir jetzt so viel erfahren mittlerweile
was hätten sie sich für den gewünscht
wer hat seine erste tat in ganz jungen
jahren begangen als er selber 14 war da
hat er die erste vergewaltigung den
ersten missbrauch versucht war dann zehn
jahre in der psychiatrie was hätten sie
sich für diesen mann für diesen jungen
gewünscht wie werden sie mit ihm
umgegangen also erstmal ist es so wir
haben viele menschen die eine einfach
den falschen weg gehen ich will das
jetzt nicht abtun aber entscheidend ist
wo sind zum beispiel auch die
präventionsprogramme es gibt schon
prävention nicht zum täter werden auch
da es gibt nur ganz wenige anlaufstellen
ja wir haben so viele pädophil
veranlagte menschen in unserem land auch
kinderschänder hier immer wieder zum
thema werden 80 über 80% rückfallquote
wir haben so wenig anders stellt wie
sollen die sich stellen auch selber
schützen nicht zum täter werden und dann
werden sie auch noch toleriert ich hatte
mir für den jungen wünscht dass er
abgefangen worden ich hätte mir für den
jungs schon gewünscht dass er damals als
er so geworden ist werden ist mit 14
dass man ihnen in der familie betreut
hat sind auch raus genommen hätte da
erst gar nicht so geworden ist der junge
ist doch nicht als mörder geboren er
habe ihn so gemacht mich hat man auch so
gemacht vom opfer zum täter mich hat man
so gemacht ich hab die kurve irgendwann
gekriegt aber ich war 18 jahren
kriminell so lange hat es gedauert ihr
kennt ja viele dinge gar nicht erlebt
ich hätte nicht gern erlebt dass meine
freundin vergewaltigt wird und und
hinfällig hätten viele dinge richtig an
aber das hier tolerieren ich nicht ich
habe null akzeptanz bei vergewaltigung
und missbrauch und 0 ups zu einer
politik die sich um alles kümmert aber
nicht über ihre eigenen bürger und vor
allem nicht um ihre eigene kinder sorry
ist wir merken es sie werden sie sehen
auch viele fälle und werden da sehr
emotional sprechen vielen menschen auch
aus dem herzen die diesen fall sehen und
sich fragen wer hat er versagt was
hätten die behörden tun können warum
weiß man nicht was dieser mann im
internet macht warum kann er sich
einfach so mit einem jungen mädchen
verabreden warum klingelt da vielleicht
nur einmal im monat jemand und sagt aha
da sind sie also und verabschiedet sich
wieder das ist etwas was bei ganz vielen
menschen zu völligem unverständnis für
kein geld da kein geld da keine keine
mitarbeiter da die ressourcen sind nicht
da ja nehmen die schule wir haben wir
haben 1500 schulpsychologen die zustände
sind für 10 millionen schüler bei der
anzahl von gewalttaten die da sind und
fassbar und wir haben auch kaum
mitarbeiter vom jugendamt kann raus
gehen und auch hier man muss einfach
gucken wie überlastet die aus sind ja
wir haben abgebaut der polizei stellen
abgebaut und wir fragen uns warum alles
schlimmer wird natürlich wenn ja wenn
wir nur mal alles weniger fahren und
nicht hochfahren weil die probleme sind
mehr geworden wir haben das
digitalisiert auch die einflüsse auch
das sage ich immer wieder den eltern
bitte lasst eure kinder nicht
unbeaufsichtigt irgendwelchen online
spielen sein das regentief das sind die
basars die supermärkte für die
kinderschänder die suchen dort gezielt
kinder und denn system haben dann
versuchen sie erst mit geld zu locken
dass sie in bilder hinschicken und wenn
sie dort gemacht haben presse ist es ihr
wissen war teilweise schon wo sie wohnen
bitte lasst uns endlich anfangen
aufzuwachen und ihn der wahrheit ins
gesicht zu sehen deutschland ist ein
paradies für kinderschänder und
vergewaltiger und kinderpornographie
deutschland ist auch unter den drei top
ländern die nicht ihre kinder schützen
cannoli sein und jetzt gehen bei der
über die koffer wir schaffen wir
langsamer der politik wahr zu machen
dazu ist das sind funktioniert damit
gezeigt im letzten jahren war viel
gesetze im bundestag getragen warum mit
dem druck den wir machen in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung aber wer hat
mehr öffentliche war nochmals ihr könnt
ihr eigentlich menschen dort machen ich
will die leute hier sitzen haben die
verantwortung deswegen berlin war sitzen
auch sie her der mit der dem ganzen eine
stimme geben damit werde druck machen
damit wir hören was auch sie in ihrer
arbeit erleben die frage die sich hier
in diesem fall immer wieder stellt ist
jemand der mit 14 jahren bereits seine
erste tat begeht überhaupt in der form
wie wir uns das wünschen und sie haben
auch ihre eigene kriminelle
vergangenheit angesprochen dieser punkt
eine kurve zu kriegen wieder eingliedern
aber in unserer gesellschaft wie viel
kraft verwenden wir darauf und muss die
kraft der überwachung eine andere werden
wir sehen wie das fängt ja schon viel
früher an warum fangen wir nicht viel
früher an schulen den schulen in den
grundschulen in den kita ist mit
prävention und aufklärung aufklärung
gegen mobbing gewalt rassismus hass auf
gegen missbrauch dass die kinder sich
anvertrauen der müsste noch passiert ist
und größten teil in den eigenen familien
wenn wir da schon versagen dann bereiten
wir das ja schon vor den weg und wenn
dir erstmal abrutschen so wie ich dann
fällt es immer weiter und dann bist du
musst schon der bodensatz der abschaum
der gesellschaft und mich so keine hilfe
mehr wir holen viele menschen unser land
weil wir helfen wollen aber wir lassen
sie sich selbst und wundern uns dass wir
dutzende hundertfache
gruppenvergewaltigung haben bedeutet das
dass deshalb menschen unter anderem
gruppen vergewaltiger sind natürlich
nicht aber wir überlassen sie sich
selbst und wollen sich das nicht
funktionieren kann das geht nicht wir
müssen integrieren wir müssen helfen und
hilfeleistung machen der junge war 14
jahre ist komplett abgedriftet gut da
war wenigstens ein gutachter hat gesagt
er ist gefährlich gab erkannt aber das
tor nicht gefährlich geboren den hat man
die 14 jahre so gemacht und wo weil die
jugendämter im vorfeld was hat man den
jungen vielleicht angetan was hat man da
jetzt solltet nicht reagiert er muss
jetzt mit voller härte bestraft werden
und die gesellschaft und menschen müssen
wir ihm geschützt werden aber wir
schaffen uns unsere täter indem wir
nicht eingreifen wenn wir es können und
hätte man präventionen bevor menschen zu
opfern und tätern werden und da wird
versagt ich danke ihnen ganz für ihre
wut bei diesem thema bei einem fall der
uns alle so aufgewühlt hat herr stahl
finden sie worte für die menschen in
gottenheim mit der heimat von aline für
die angehörigen
ich war auf 8 beerdigungen und auf
mehreren man machen es nimmt mich jedes
mal mit bin jedes mal zu tränen gerührt
und sehe diese verzweiflung in den
menschen warum passiert das hier es
passiert überall es fehlten nur den
kleinen städten mit kleineren namen er
auf ich kann den bürgern nur sagen
haltet das gedenken an aline aufrecht
vergisst sie nicht macht eine mahnwache
macht gedenktage las sie unvergessen
sein denn wenn wir anfangen diese kinder
zu vergessen dann fangen wir an als
gesellschaft immer mehr abzustumpfen und
es ist doch nicht nur einer alien ich
war an so vielen beerdigungen cup so
viele kinder gesehen die weit vor ihrer
zeit gegangen sind und will dort nicht
mehr ich hätte heute jung der wert 25
jahre alt der wurde getötet durch eine
gruppe weiter und deshalb müssen wir
daraus lernen wir können die
vergangenheit nicht ändern aber wir
müssen die zukunft ändern für unsere
kinder denn sie sind unsere zukunft die
moral einer gesellschaft zeigt sich in
dem was sie für ihre kinder tut hat
dietrich bonhoeffer gesagt also bitte
worauf warten wir die politik nicht
machen die politik hört nur auf 1 auf
öffentlichen druck da tagen neun jahren
bitterer erfahrung kinderschutz gelernt
carsten scheibe deutliche worte starke
worte worte die mit die ins herz treffen
danke dass sie hier in dieser sendung
sagen danke dass du nicht raus geht es
darüber zu reden und das hat uns alle
hier aufgerüttelt was und wie unsere
reporterin aus frankfurt vor wenigen
stunden hierbei bild live berichtet hat
unsere reporterin jessica fehler die
nach einer neuen schießerei ins
frankfurter bahnhofsviertel gefahren ist
mal wieder und verzweifelt an ihrer
stadt die dort immer mehr verkommt immer
mehr zur no-go-area wird
ich liebe meine stadt möglich aber das
bahnhofsviertel ist wirklich so ein
viertel wo ich sage ich fühle mich hier
nicht sicher als frau schon gar nicht es
ist das eingang zu unserer stadt es ist
eine katastrophe
diese die die komplette lage ist ja
immer ja ich liebe meine stadt aber es
wird eine katastrophe hier im
bahnhofsviertel das also waren die worte
von meiner reporter kollegin jessica
verleiht dort in frankfurt im
bahnhofsviertel auch ein hilferuf warum
ändert sich hier nichts warum lässt man
das bahnhofsviertel so zu einer no go
area verkommen und der anlass für diese
reportage ja der war das hier eine neue
schießerei in diesem hotel dort in dem
bahnhofsviertel in der moselstraße ganz
genau einsatz von polizei spezialkräften
bedrohungslage am ende erschießt ein
polizist ein mann und es ist ja immer
noch nicht ganz klar was genau dort
vorgefallen ist schüsse polizeigewalt
drogenexzesse alltag im frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel
zusammen geschlagen ausgeraubt liegen
gelassen immer wieder macht das
frankfurter bahnhofsviertel bundesweit
schlagzeilen erst vor zwei wochen
schockierte dieses handy video
deutschland ein mann wird umzingelt und
mit voller wucht ins gesicht geschlagen
er liegt bewusstlos am boden dann wird
er ausgeraubt das frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel
hotspot der heroin und crack zähne ein
brennpunkt für gewalt prostitution und
drogen auf offener straße werden drogen
gespritzt geschnupft und gedealt und
immer wieder eskaliert die situation
diese woche dann der traurige höhepunkt
spezialkräfte der polizei rückten am
dienstagmorgen an erschießen einen
23-jährigen in diesem hotel was sich
hier genau abspielte unklar fest steht
nur als die spezialkräfte anrücken
eskaliert die lage schüsse der 23
jährige stirbt dann seinen schweren
verletzungen
vorfälle wie diese sind der grund dafür
weshalb bürger das bahnhofsviertel von
frankfurt schon lange meiden die gegend
wird immer mehr zur no-go-area
mitarbeiter der müllbeseitigung können
teilweise nur unter polizeischutz ihrer
arbeit im bahnhofsviertel verrichten
unglaubliche zustände
die frankfurter sind entsetzt ich liebe
meine stadt aber ich schäme mich so ein
bisschen für dieses viertel wie ich
fühle mich ja auch nicht sicher die
junkies lauern so ein bisschen in den
ecken wenn man reinkommt der eine
schießt sich grad was in die armbeuge
der andere machten nickerchen auf dem
nächsten tag vor den kiosken werden
substanzen ausgetauscht sich durch die
nase gezogen
das bahnhofsviertel 1 das tor zur stadt
heute das tor zur hölle
es sind verstörende bilder die uns immer
wieder aus dem frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel erreichen bilder die
schockieren wie viel muss hier noch
passieren
[Musik]